>>> Tonight, Donald Trump's
former lawyer Michael Cohen
testifying before a grand jury
investigating hush money
payments made to adult film star
stormy Daniels.
Here he is on his way out of the
courthouse tonight.
>> This isn't a question of
vindication.
It's not a question as I stated
before about revenge.
This is a -- my position is that
at the end of the day Donald
Trump needs to be held
accountable for his dirty deeds
if, in fact, that's the way that
the facts play out.
>> Daniels also today meeting
with the Manhattan district
attorney's office.
Trump has been invited to appear
before the grand jury which is
the clearest indication yet that
prosecutors are nearing a
decision on whether to take the
unprecedented step of indicting
a former president.
Out front now, trump's attorney
Joe tacopina.
I appreciate your time.
You heard Michael Cohen coming
out today moments ago.
What's your response to him?
>> I mean, look, Allen Bragg
once said and I hope he
remembers these words, he can't
see a world in which he would
base a prosecution of Donald
Trump on the word of a convicted
perjurer and felon like Michael
Cohen.
He's still a convicted perjurer
and he's someone who is
convicted of lying and it's not
about vengeance.
It's all about vengeance for him
and putting that aside, Erin.
Here's the question.
Does anyone actually believe,
anyone, left, right, middle,
whatever that if someone else
were accused of paying hush
money to avoid a public sex
scandal in the manner that
Donald Trump is allegeded to
have avoided a public sex
scandal they would be prosecute,
the answer is 100% no.
And we cannot as a society,
pro-trump, anti-Trump, left,
right, want the weaponization of
the justice system or a
prosecutor's office to pursue
political opponents with -- with
rule of law.
It's just not right and that's
exactly what's happening here.
>> I want to ask you about that,
but first on the point you said
about Michael Cohen, convicted
perjurer.
Yes, and he served his time, but
the fdny is not going to indict
based on what Michael Cohen
says.
If they would have done that,
they would have done that a long
time ago.
They heard from other witnesses,
kellyanne Conway appeared there,
hope hicks appeared there.
Does any of that give you pause?
>> Yeah, well, it gives me
confidence it should give Alan
Bragg pause.
The southern district of new
York is the top echelon, the
holy grail, if you will of
prosecutor's offices in this
country.
They had plenty of time to
indict former president trump if
they wanted to and they chose
not to because they not that
campaign election law makes it
very clear that there was no
violation.
Erin, if there was no campaign
law violation here there is no
case at all.
At all.
>> I understand someone who was
involved in that the other day
told me that time had passed,
when that decision was made not
to indict and they thought, you
know what?
They could have had more
information.
They could have figured it out
and they're not going to move
without having that, right?
That they've got the goods.
>> Well, that they've got the
goods.
They evaluated it and didn't go
forward.
The Manhattan d.a.'s office,
despite what they said about
relying on Michael Cohen in the
past, for three years they have
scoured Donald Trump's personal
and business life.
Scoured, and they've lookeded
for a crime to fit the person,
we should all be concerned about
this, whether you like or hate
Donald Trump, we should all be
concerned, they picked the
person and are searching for a
crime if you read Pomerantz's
book by revealing secret grand
jury information to a third
party, in his book, even he said
that he picked trump.
He would have paid to prosecute
trump which is a scary statement
by a pros cure, but he would
have paid to prosecute him
because he didn't like him 37.
>> One, if a crime is there,
misdemeanor or felony, if a
crime is there a kram is there,
right?
>> Absolutely.
>> I know you said Donald Trump
will win the election, if they
bring this case I believe it
will catapult him to the white
house, that's what you said last
night, but if that's the case,
they surely would know that,
too.
Why would they be going ahead
and doing this for political
reasons if it's only going to
help him?
>> Listen, Erin.
They may not see it the way I
see it.
They may think if they indict
someone it makes them ineligible
to run for president.
There are some states that you
can be disqualified from running
on the ballot if you have an
open indictment.
>> Look, I think it will
embolden his supporters and I
think it will enrange his
supporters and make them feel
stronger about the fact that
they're politicizing the justice
department system and a
prosecutor would say he's a very
democratic prosecutor that's
been supportive by the far left
going after the far right guy
out there, and I think he's
thinking if I prosecute him I
tack him out of candacy and that
is not what a prosecutor's
office should be doing.
>> An indictment does not mean
he can't run.
Is he prepared to appear in
court to defend himself?
>> One thing I will tell you
about Donald Trump in MI time
knowing him and representing him
and having the honor of
representing, is he's probably
the toughest guy I've ever met
because most people would buckle
under this pressure.
Is he prepared?
He's prepared.
I'm prepared.
Susan Nicholas' is prepared and
my co-counsel will lean on this
thing.
We're prepared and this case
will be eaten up and it fails on
the law and it fails on the
facts.
He's prepared.
Does he want this to happen?
Of course, not.
Does anyone want to be charged
falsely for a crime of political
persecution?
Of course not.
All we have to look at is the
facts of the law and it is very
clear.
Campaign finance law is very
You have scholars and former
chairmen of the federal and
state campaign finance
committees who have all said,
all opined, show me one who says
differently that these facts
make out a crime.
They do not.
>> The only thing I'd say is if
it would embolden the supporters
why don't you want them to go
ahead and charge and it sounds
like you're talking out of both
sides of your mouth.
>> Don't say I'm talking out of
both sides of my mouth, if they
indict him, I think it will
embolden him because he will win
this case and it will catapult
him to the white house.
That's what I said.
What I am also saying is no one
in their right mind wants to be
indicted and charged falsely of
a crime.
I'm not talking about both sides
of my mouth.
I am stating facts and it will
ultimately embolden supporters
because he'll be proven to be
wrongly accused and who wants to
be charged falsely with a crime?
Nobody.
>> Joe tacopina, thank you for
your time.
>> The editor in chief of the
just security blog.
Here we are, a likely indictment
is pending here.
What's your takeaway from Joe
tacopina?
>> I thought what was most
curious or what he didn't talk
about.
He's talking about things that
are not crimes or not the
central crime.
Nobody would be charged for hush
money.
That's true, because paying hush
money is not a crime.
>> Right.
>> He wants to talk about the
campaign finance charges and
that is shakier, but the central
charge that he will bring is
falsifying business records that
when they paid Michael Cohen
they did not say that the
payment was for its true purpose
and it was legal services and
that he was on retainer and that
is what the central charge was a
misdemeanor and everything
builds off of that.
>> Just a misdemeanor on that
and just to be clear.
Charges are charges and there
are a lot of other cases out
there, but a misdemeanor you're
talking about a fine if
convicted.
>> If it all boils down to just
that charge of a misdemeanor
then this is not about Donald
Trump facing jail time and
that's a good chance that
happens with this case.
Unclear, right?
Whether more information came in
as Joe and I were talking about.
But if this happens, it will be
the first indictment of possibly
several because you have the
classified documents and Fulton
county Georgia, and in that
case, we have learned that
there's a new call, a new phone
call that we have not heard
about that was trump and he made
this call to the Georgia house
speaker and it was to push a
special session to overturn the
election.
We know about this phone call.
This is the third audio
recording on trump and we did
not know about this until now.
How valuable is the evidence?
>> I think it's incredibly
valuable and that's not just the
existence of the phone call and
he's trying to set up a special
session with the house speaker
GOP leader pushes back, but it's
an audio recording of the phone
call.
That's very important.
It's vivid information that has
an inherent reliability and
credibility for a jury, that can